Уряд Німеччини вимагає від Путіна збереження
українського транзиту російського газу.
Однак парадокс полягає в тому, що останніми роками
саме офіційний Берлін активно підтримував "Газпром"
у створенні інфраструктури в обхід України.
Навіть якщо Москві і Києву вдасться домовитися
щодо умов транзиту з наступного року, про колишні
обсяги транзиту російського газу Україні можна забути.
Найбільшим транзитером російського газу стане Німеччина.
Після введення в експлуатацію "Північного потоку-2"
"Газпром" напряму - через Балтійське море - зможе постачати до ФРН
110 мільярдів кубометрів газу на рік.
Але сама Німеччина використовує лише приблизно 35 мільярдів кубометрів.
Тож головне призначення "Північного потоку-2" - це саме транзит.
Східноєвропейські держави - країни Балтії і Польща -
серйозно критикували цей проект.
Вони не хочуть зміцнювати відносини з Росією,
а хочуть відмовитися від російського газу.
Німеччина ж навпаки протягом кількох десятиліть
була надійним і великим споживачем російського газу.
І прямі поставки обсягом понад 100 мільярдів кубометрів
німці явно направлятимуть в інші країни Європи - на південь і на захід.
Через трубопровідну мережу Німеччини російський газ
можна постачати до більшості країн Європи.
Німецький експерт з газових ринків Роланд Ґетц
не бачить суперечності в будівництві прямого газопроводу
з Росії і підтримці збереження українського транзиту.
Навіть коли "Північний потік -2" буде запущено,
було б розумно з економічної точки зору зберегти частину
української мережі щонайменше в якості резерву.
По-перше, на випадок аварій газопроводу.
Ремонт або технічне обслуговування "Північного потоку"
можуть зайняти кілька тижнів.
А по-друге, можливо, імпорт газу в Європу зросте
у зв'язку з відмовою від вугільних електростанцій.
До того ж, Німеччина та ще кілька країн ЄС відмовляються також від атомної енергії.
Втім, у Німецькому інституті економічних досліджень
вважають помилковими прогнози про збільшення попиту на газ у Європі.
Професорка Клаудіа Кемферт переконана, що "Північний потік-2" Німеччині не потрібен.
Ми не вважаємо, що буде потрібен додатковий газ.
Ми знайомі з цими прогнозами і вже протягом двадцяти років їх спростовуємо.
Постійно кажуть, що газу буде споживатися більше,
але насправді ми будемо споживати його дедалі менше.
З екологічних причин газопроводи ставатимуть дедалі менш прибутковими.
Їх будуть субсидіювати, але використовувати будуть все менше.
При цьому, як зазначають експерти, не можна заперечувати і геополітичної складової в тому,
що Німеччина в будь-якому випадку забере собі
щонайменше частину українського транзиту.
Єврокомісія і східноєвропейські країни звинувачували Німеччину
в спробах підірвати енергетичну безпеку цих країн.
І як відповідь на цю критику Меркель постійно висловлювалася за те,
щоб частина поставок російського газу йшла через Україну,
щоб Київ не втратив усі транзитні збори від "Газпрому".
Хоча оператор "Північного потоку-2" - компанія Nord Stream 2
зі штаб-квартирою в швейцарському Цугу
є 100-відсотковою дОнькою "Газпрому", в проекті беруть участь і німецькі фірми.
Анґела Меркель підтримувала будівництво "Північного потоку-2",
підкреслюючи насамперед його економічну доцільність.
Що стосується "Північного потоку-2", то це суто економічний проект.
Але статус найбільшого транзитера російського газу
може принести Берліну не лише економічні дивіденди.
Німеччина підвищує не просто економічний, а політичний статус,
якщо вона стає розподільником газу на великій території Європи - аж до Італії.
Італія нині отримує газ через Україну, а в майбутньому,
можливо, доведеться отримувати через Німеччину, Чехію та Австрію.
Тому тут питання престижу і якогось прибутку.
Долю українського газового транзиту мають
вирішити протягом найближчих тижнів.